there's a lot of fakeness in this
country but is there a corporation in
america faker than patagonia
it's a marketing company that poses as a
mountaineering expedition in order to
sell shoddily made plastic clothing to
non-profit executives who rarely go
outside
patagonia's promotional materials
describe its total dedication to
fighting climate change but somehow they
forget to mention that its entire
product line is made from fossil fuels
patagonia is the kind of place that will
give you a lecture about fair trade and
corporate responsibility
even as it outsources its own
manufacturing to grubby sweatshops in
the world's most impoverished countries
enjoy your 300 casual wear hoodie mr
sierra club fundraiser some kid in sri
lanka got 20 cents to make it
patagonia may be the single most
audacious scam in all of american
business and that's saying something so
it probably shouldn't surprise you that
patagonia has now decided it should
control american politics
earlier this month a group of republican
office holders including former white
house chief of staff mark meadows
members of congress jim jordan and
marjorie taylor greene flew to jackson
wyoming for a private fundraiser now by
itself this was not unusual raising
money in resort towns is what
politicians do in august
unfortunately the group forgot to ask
patagonia first when patagonia
executives discovered that republicans
had traveled to wyoming without their
permission
they threw a fit they announced a
boycott of the entire jackson hole ski
resort their reasoning
their company they explained in a press
release supports quote a strong
democracy
of course
a strong democracy
is a system where a small group of smug
inherited money billionaires decide
who's allowed to speak in public and who
had better shut up or face punishment
now we used to call that system
oligarchy
but the term had an unpleasant
authoritarian ring so the marketing
geniuses at patagonia renamed it it's
now called democracy
that's a little like taking spun
polyester fiber made from oil and
calling it shearling wool which comes
from sheep and hoping no one will notice
in fact come to think of it patagonia
has done that too
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else